[Music]
foreign
the
French police are regaining order
they've swamped the streets with
officers and appeals for calm were
backed by the grandmother of 17 year old
nahal mazuk who was shot dead by the
police last Tuesday
the people who are pillaging stop stop
they're using Nile as a pretext no they
must stop destroying the shops the
schools the buses the mothers take the
buses we take the buses
family are from non-taire a suburb in
Western Paris it's here where he died
it has torn this community apart
police not welcome
the few officers we saw were staring out
on the edge of the neighborhood this
place has seen some of the worst of the
violence over the last week and there is
now an uneasy piece here there are lots
of young men on the street corners
watching who goes in and who goes out
it still feels pretty tense
the weekend also saw a more Sinister
targeted attack
building car was driven at the home of a
mayor of one of the Southern suburbs of
Paris he wasn't at home but his wife and
one of his children were injured while
trying to escape it's being investigated
as attempted murder
I would never have imagined that someone
would threaten my family with death and
that there would be an assassination
attempt in this beautiful city president
macron will feel that his response is
now working this was the calmest night
since the killing but it is fragile
the anger runs deep here and through
communities across France
Tom Parmenter Sky News Paris